[Applause]
thanks very much as they said I'm young
and I work at ASI data science and we
are a data science consultancy we do
data science training and we build a
data science platform and I work on the
consulting team mostly and a little bit
on the platform and today I want to talk
about how humans can support algorithms
and vice versa with the interactive
Python ecosystem so I'm gonna start by
doing some fairly basic and fairly crude
because they're taken from Wikipedia and
overviews of machine learning and so
most people who sort of start out
learning machine machine learning and
learn about supervised learning which is
you know learning a function that map's
an input to an output based on example
input-output pairs and in particular we
often call this label data right so you
have a big set of label data you want to
train some sort of algorithm and some
model in order to be able to predict
maybe unseen input data and basically
learn this sort of input to label
mapping and then the other sort of side
of the coin is unsupervised machine
learning and where we usually don't have
labels so we have unlabeled data and
instead what we want to do is sort of
understand the structure of the data and
so often this involves clustering and
various approaches like that and they
help you sort of figure out what's
inside your data maybe identify sort of
groups of points that are defined by
being sort of near to each other in
feature space and that may be all have
the same label and if you were to have
labels and so obviously supervised
learning isn't pretty advanced these
days so and there's great libraries in
order to do it it's pretty
straightforward and if you have a lot of
data and it's good data and you can
achieve pretty high accuracies at
predicting labels unsupervised learning
is getting that you know you can do
really amazing stuff with unsupervised
learning algorithms but ultimately of
what you want to do is predict some
labels and maybe you know which labels
you predict you just don't have any
examples of it in your data and you're
going to struggle a little bit and so
ideally what you want to do is you have
unlabeled data and you may be doing some
unsupervised learning and you're going
to start moving towards using supervised
machine learning algorithms in order to
start predicting your data and there's
sort of something in the middle which
not that many people learn about when
they start out doing sort of ML courses
which is semi-supervised learning where
you have some label data but you also
have a lot of unlabeled data and you
want to start training algorithms that
take into account both and so usually
that you know means that you sort of
make some assumptions about your data
about the labels and the unlabeled data
may be that they all lie on some sort of
continuous manifold or that there's some
sort of clustering inside your data and
you try and extend the sort of labels
that you do have towards the data that
you don't have labels for and try and
improve your algorithm that way and so
that is the main thing I want to talk
about today and in particular a sort of
subset of this which really comes back
to the sort of moving from unsupervised
learning to supervised learning and that
is active learning which is the case
where you have some supervised machine
learning algorithm and the algorithm is
able to interactively query some
information source and that's usually a
user or a data scientist and is able to
basically obtain new labels so it's able
to ask ok I'm starting to make some
predictions but I'd like to improve can
you tell me the label for this
particular data point and then hopefully
it will sort of improve iteratively like
that and so I've got some diagrams to
illustrate this using a fairly simple
case if you have some 2d data that's
mostly unlabeled so those are the gray
points but you have two labels the red
and the green and you train some sort of
linear model
you might get a model that has a sort of
function that looks like the red dashed
lines here and so you have some sort of
decision boundary in the middle plus
some uncertainty area because maybe
you're using a parametric model where
you can estimate the sort of variance of
your model parameters and now we want to
know a how good is this and B how can we
improve this and what we could do is
just that labeling more points right we
could just look at some of these points
and the user could look at it saying
these are images the user could look at
it and say okay that is a horse which is
fine but what we want to do is do this
in a sort of relatively smart way and we
can because we have some information
about a model at this stage right we
know the decision function of this model
and so what we might want to do is not
just query a random point but query a
point that is fairly close to the
decision boundary and where the model is
relatively an uncertain compared to some
of the other points in the feature space
and so then we label that point and it's
a red point and so our decision function
shifts to this and now we can label some
more points because now we have a new
model we have a new decision function
and we have a different relationship
between the points and that decision
function right so we could now start to
you know if we were to want to sort of
efficiently label this we can maybe
label this point because it's fairly
close to the decision boundary and if
that's a Green Point then we're starting
to really shift our decision function
the uncertainty area shrinks by quite a
lot and you know we're really getting
somewhere with this model and our
predictions on the unseen on the
unlabeled data so that's a fairly sort
of simplistic example using low
dimensional data and fairly
straightforward model but the sort of
basics of the active learning process
pretty much there right so it's these
five steps where you train some
supervised model on labelled data you
then use that model to make predictions
on unlabeled data and then you somehow
use the information that your model is
giving you to prioritize the unlabeled
data
and then you use that prioritization to
label more data and then you rinse and
repeat until you have labeled quite a
lot of data and maybe I achieve them
some performance that you're satisfied
with so I want to mainly talk about the
yellow parts just because you know
training is supervised model is a whole
nother talks worth of information and
making predictions especially using sort
of supervised learning libraries is
pretty pretty good pretty easy these
days and Python and just to sort of come
back to why using this approach is
really nice is that we use exactly the
same models that we used in standard
sort of supervised machine learning to
do this process we don't have to really
change very much we can probably use the
same Python libraries for it and
hopefully we don't need to sort of learn
anything new about about algorithms that
we're not familiar with okay and so to
talk about these various steps I'm gonna
straight it with a library that I've
written for this purpose which is called
superintendent and which heavily sort of
leverages the interactive Python
ecosystem because ultimately you don't
want to spend ages building some sort of
labeling app where people you know can
click on buttons and stuff instead what
you want to do is use the existing sort
of infrastructure that Python already
provides and in particular Jupiter and a
sort of ipython ecosystem to do this
very seamlessly and painlessly and
that's sort of trying to create ok so
we're just going to start with the first
step which is we want to train a
supervised model on some label data so
that means if we don't have any labels
at the beginning we need to create some
labels and I'm just gonna demonstrate
that this is our data sense platform but
ultimately this is just a Jupiter
notebook as you will see and I'm going
to demonstrate this stuff with you know
the classic the eminence digit data set
where that I'm just importing from SK
learn here where we've got some images
that we want to classify us whether
they're the digits from 0 to 9 and
obviously we have labels for this but
let's pretend that we don't and so what
we want to start doing is create some
initial labels I've just selected a
thousand of these images they all look
roughly like this so they're fairly
low-resolution but we want to you know
start labeling these and so what I'm
gonna do is the class that you need for
this from the superintendent package and
then I will create a data labeling
widget and I'm gonna use because these
are images I'm gonna use a factory
function that creates it sort of to
display images because obviously images
isn't the only thing that you want to
label and these days and I'm gonna pass
it the features that I created earlier
so hopefully that will work and then I
can start to label it and I happen to
know that this data set has the digits
from 0 to 9 to 9 minutes I'm gonna
specify that the options that I want to
be labeling with are from 0 to 9 and so
then we've kind of got based on the sort
of IPA widgets and framework a sort of
labeling object that we can start to use
to label and so I can start clicking on
these buttons and create labels for my
data and you're not seeing it because
I'm doing it very slowly but you're
getting a little progress bar up here as
well and so you always know how much
you've got left to do and you can then
because this is just a Python object
access these labels immediately so most
of these are none because I haven't done
that much work
but you can see that my labels are in
here and so if we wanted to I can now
start training a model right and I don't
have much data but I could cool so that
is the first step so we have we have
achieved some label data now I want to
do is we want to use the labels that we
have created to prioritize the labels
that we still need to create and so
that's step 3 and I'm just going to
quickly talk about sort of how you might
do that because for the simple case of
the linear model that I had earlier it's
maybe pretty straightforward but with a
more complex model where you don't have
access to the actual decision function
it's not so easy to say okay this point
is right on the decision boundary but
what most active learning algorithms
rely on is the simple fact that you get
continuous model output from quite a lot
of different machine learning algorithms
and so this is where you can test your
own handwritten digit recognition
algorithms using my diagrams here but if
you have you know the two images on the
left so this 4 and this 8 and you're
passing it through some model then
you're getting some continuous output
from that and that might be the
probabilities of the different labels
and if you've got a model that produces
that but it could also just be you know
the softmax output layer from a neural
network or something like that as long
as it's continuous and as long as the
actual values of this output correspond
in some way to the sort of certainty
that you have about the label and so for
example if this algorithm has seen quite
a lot of fours then for the first image
it might produce probabilities like the
ones on the top where everything is
fairly low but the probability of it
being a4 is quite high and so you know
we're fairly certain that and this is a4
whereas the image on the bottom because
it's a fairly badly written 8 maybe the
probability of 8 is quite high but
actually the probability of 0 is a
little bit higher so that's the one that
wins out here
so how do we then use this continuous
model output to prioritize the data so
I'm going to talk about two simple ways
of doing that the first one is to sample
your unlabeled data using the sort of
entropy of these predictions and so you
just compute the entropy across the
different probabilities of the labels in
this case you know the top the top
prediction is fairly certain so the
entropy is quite low because most of the
information is in you know in one label
where's the entropy for the bottom
continuous model output is quite high so
we prioritize that point over the top
point and note that this is kind of
regardless of whether we know whether
that the label that the model is
producing for ade here is correct or not
right we're not actually evaluating the
accuracy of the model here we're just
saying okay we happen to know that this
model is fairly certain about the top
image but not very certain about the
bottom image so that's nice that would
be one way of doing it and another
fairly simple way is to simply compute
the margin in between the top
probability and the second highest
probability so in this case the model is
91% certain so it has a 90 91 percent
probability of the labor four and the
next highest probability is 1% so the
margin is 0.9 whereas for the bottom
image the margin is 0.02 we take the
image that has the smallest margin and
start to label those images and so this
is another way of kind of quantifying
the sort of certainty of the model about
the various images and therefore
prioritizing which images we need to
sample first we need to label first and
just to sort of illustrate that this can
be quite powerful this is from paper
about active learning where they're
comparing different active learning sort
of prioritization mechanisms with just
selecting at random which is on the red
line here and as you can see the B vs B
which is actually the margin something I
just spoke about and performs quite a
lot better than the random sampling and
you achieve much higher performance
much quicker cool so how do we do that
in Python
well first we maybe need to collapse
some of these cells and so what we want
to do is we want to first choose an
algorithm that we're using here right
because that's in order to get this
continuous model output you need some
model and so I'm just gonna import a
very simple one which is a logistic
regression which isn't exactly
state-of-the-art for Amnesty Jets but it
achieves about 94% accuracy and I'm just
going to use the default parameters for
this model as well so I've created a
model which sort of conforms to the
standard SK learn you know fit predict
interface and then I can just pass that
to my labeling in widget as a classifier
I need to specify how this widget is
going to reorder the data anytime I
asked it to and then I also need to
specify how much of this sort of
reordering is supposed to be done at
random in this case I'm just going to
choose zero because it makes the
demonstration a bit easier and then I
can start labeling and so I obviously
started with zero label data but I can
start labeling in exactly the same way
as I did before so I'm gonna skip and
create some labels that we use to sort
of seed the algorithm that we're
training here so he's a really hard
and once I have created some of these
labels I can hit this retrain button and
that's going to retrain the model and at
the same time reorder all the subsequent
images that I'm going to label based on
the metric that are specified here which
is this margin sampling of the top two
probabilities of the model output and so
what we'll see is that we're sort of
starting to explore fairly similar areas
of the feature space right this zero is
fairly similar to the six and presumably
that's why they're sort of margin
between the top two probabilities is
fairly low and then we've got two five
so the model is clearly not yet certain
about fives and we're starting to sort
of explore the feature space where it
maybe is most useful to the model and we
can then keep doing that and keep
retraining the data and hopefully start
to sort of teach the model a lot more
about the areas of the feature space
that it doesn't get know about note that
the score here is still fairly bad I
haven't labeled very many images and in
particular and mainly labeling the
really hard images right and this is
where this sort of shuffle proportion
comes in because in order to assess your
model performance which is this value
here you really want to have a fairly
representative sample of your feature
space which I'm not doing here so you
want to have some randomly sampled
images in order to be able to produce
your sort of model score cool so that's
how you might want how you might sort of
do this active learning and using this
library and this is the next step this
is what I just did you then once you
prioritize your data you want to label
more and more of it right so you want to
keep going this I've just done and then
ultimately what you want to do is repeat
this lots and lots of times right
especially if you have a big data set
where maybe you're not quite certain
that sampling a small portion of it will
sort of hit all the different areas and
maybe find all the sort of you know
minority classes in your data set
and that can be quite boring as you just
saw sorry about that and so what I am
trying to would have built into this
library is the ability to sort of
distribute this across a few different
people and so ideally what you want to
do is you want to collect all the labels
that people are creating and train an
algorithm based on that based on all of
the data that different people are
providing then reorder it and then have
everybody who's doing the labeling and
you know take it take the next sort of
images or next data that they're
labeling and from that sort of same
stack of data that that you're kind of
labeling and so in order to do that you
can connect this library to a database
where essentially you can have the two
people at the top create a widget to
take sort of images off this queue which
sits in the database and just keep
labeling and they don't even know about
the algorithm that you're using to
reorder this and then you can have the
person at the bottom or you know the
serve at the bottom run this
orchestration function which keeps
retraining the model periodically and
keeps reordering the data based on
whatever method of sort of reordering
you've chosen and I'm just going to
demonstrate that as well so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to spin up a
completely different server which is
going to do this stuff for me and all
you need to do on that server is run a
script that looks like this where
effectively you're doing a lot of the
stuff that we just did in the in the
notebook you sort of import a model and
then in particular you need a sort of
database connection which just follows
this sort of SQL alchemy database
connection string format and then you
provide that to your Python object here
and in particular you import the widget
from a you know sub package call it
distributed and then you just run this
orchestration function and by default it
will sort of retrain the model every 30
seconds and then reorder the data and
obviously that means that
can have the server that is sort of
doing this orchestration be much more
powerful than the labeling service or
the you know people's individual laptops
or whatever you're using and to actually
run the labeling and I'm just gonna run
this and then anybody can you know in
their Jupiter notebook do exactly the
same load the same sort of database
connection in so again it looks a bit
like this and start labeling and because
I've practiced this talk and you can see
that there's actually a bit of progress
here already and I can start sort of
labeling the data and if I had people
working with me on this they might be
doing the same thing by themselves but
we're all sort of labeling from the same
queue I'm just gonna provide the
different options here cool so you know
in theory that means you can have lots
and lots of people doing this we've done
this with about 20 people at the same
time it's been quite useful for us
building a sort of face recognition
algorithm and it does speed up labeling
by quite a lot and cool and so just to
finish that up I've got a few different
things planned for this package you know
adding additional front-end options
because you might not want to have to
require people to actually and run a
Jupiter server by themselves adding sort
of cue different queueing systems and
adding specific use cases so I've been
using this sort of image factory method
to to create these widgets doing
something more specific what an LP would
be nice and implementing different
active learning algorithms would be nice
as well and so if anybody is sort of
interested in that sort of stuff and has
experience with it and let me know and
please contribute and also please use it
cool thanks very much
[Applause]
so what questions questions to the
extent you're focused on retraining
labels based on this cross-entropy
concept hi how are you ultimately
judging accuracy is the assumption you
still have some sort of label test set
holdout and that's what you're measuring
the ultimate model well you start out
with at least in the sort of fairly
simple case you start out with
absolutely no levels right so you it's
quite hard to sort of think about the
concept of a holdout set the way this
sort of score appears calculated is
using a sort of three fold cross
validation and so it's actually
evaluating on the data that you've
labeled because in theory that's the
only labels that you have so this is why
you know labeling the sort of edge cases
as I was doing here it doesn't lead to a
particularly big improvement on those
edge cases itself because those are the
hard images right and but if you want to
have that sort of this metric be a bit
more representative of your whole data
set you could sort of increase the run
and proportion of images that you're
labeling and sort of try and get a
fairly representative sample of your
feature space and that was gonna be my
other question do you ever see any sort
of anecdotal comments on in terms of
sorting that the highest entropy
observations to real able yeah what
percent of the total training set on
every batch do you need to focus on to
start to get accelerated accuracy
improvement and so usually if your model
doesn't if the sort of forward passed
through your model doesn't take too long
then ideally you actually evaluate the
entropy of your predictions on every
single unlabeled data point which
ideally gives you the sort of best
chance of catching the sort of edge
cases that will improve your model I
mean with the sort of image recognition
stuff people usually do this in sort of
batches of 50
they look at the entire dataset and when
they're sort of reordering it
yeah so the question is whether you can
actually sort of put this into
deployment and use it to sort of
continuously update whatever and you're
trying to deploy and I suppose yes I
don't run any landing pages so I haven't
done that particular use case and mainly
we use this wind sort of building models
that we then later deploy and so I
haven't I haven't deployed any of this
live
yes so that's definitely possible
because ultimately what you're doing
here is you're just providing any model
whether that is pre trained or whether
that is sort of completely fresh and the
main worry with that would be that
you're kind of making predictions now
you'll see my screensaver that you're
making predictions on data using a pre
trained model and then reordering the
data based on those predictions right so
so the problem there is that you might
the model might start out being
completely certain about specific points
in the feature space but it might be
completely wrong so yeah would it be
easy to integrate with like Amazon Dirk
type services I think so again something
I haven't actually done but that is what
this was sort of initially designed to
to be so we're currently experimenting
with a different front-end for this
which is using Flatley - which actually
produces you know a website and so
people don't need to actually deploy
anything on their own machines and and
that works pretty well
yeah yeah absolutely that is definitely
a limitation of this process in general
using humans to label the data and I
don't think that's particularly
exacerbated by this the main thing that
you need to sort of make sure is that
you have this skip option so people
actually don't label something when
they're not very sure about it
yeah so that that's definitely something
that you need to be careful about and in
particular we have this other option by
default and so you know when we were
labeling faces for example building a
sort of face recognition thing you need
to be able to just say okay this is a
person that we haven't seen before so
let's ignore this or create a new label
for it could you use the microphone
please hey have you encountered this
problem that the active sampling items
gives you items that are very similar to
each other because I actually
implemented this sampling strategy and
that was the problem that I had and also
in this case retraining step to
basically overnight so I can't really do
it often so yeah yeah definitely and so
usually if the model is uncertain about
a particular area and feature space and
you have a lot of data in that area of
the feature space then yes those will be
the ones that sort of get and get shown
initially and then if you're not
retraining very often then you're kind
of over sampling that part of the
feature space and that's partly why I've
implemented this sort of shuffle
proportion here because you want to
still be able to randomly sample in
addition to using this sort of active
labeling and just because otherwise you
might end up completely you know under
sampling the areas that of sort of the
images that you know you have lots of
and that you want to be really sure
about yeah the sort of retraining thing
in particular obviously when you're
building bigger algorithms you want a
lot more compute and so that's why this
sort of orchestration thing where the
computing happens on a different machine
to the labeling is quite nice because
then you can make that arbitrarily large
[Music]
[Applause]